bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
petite discussion tranquille autour d'un
café petite discussion pour laquelle je
l'accueille ma collaboratrice de
toujours sophie ben sophie bonjour
bonjour julien
donc aujourd'hui nous allons discuter
tranquillement mais quand même de façon
argumentée sérieusement de la question
et si une autre espèce qu'homo sapiens
était devenu intelligence intelligente
pardon quelle serait cette espèce et
comment aurait-elle évolué donc
peut-être je vais donner la parole à
sophie pour le pour le commencement
quels sont vos pensées autour de ce
sujet avait déjà c'est un sacré
programme qu'on a devant nous parce que
c'est un gros sujet puis après on parle
d'intelligence mais l'intelligence
sépare c'est pas si simple à définir
pour commencer parce que voilà plein de
formes d'intelligence j'imagine qu'on
parle de l'intelligence humaine en
l'occurrence donc quelque chose qui peut
qui peut plus ou moins ce sera aux
autres par un test de qi bien que ça
aussi on n'est en soi pas tout le monde
soit pas exactement d'accord sur ce que
le test de qi sont exactement et la
manière de quantifier l'intelligence
grâce à ça donc ouais je vois ce que tu
veux dire le truc c'est que quand on
parle d'intelligence et d'évolution de
l'intelligence le premier obstacle je
pense qu'on rencontre c'est déjà la
définition de l'intelligence est bon on
sait tous de quoi on parle
individuellement quand on parle
d'intelligence mais quand il s'agit de
le quantifier quand il s'agit d'en faire
quelque chose de scientifiquement
observable ça devient tout de suite un
cauchemar parce que ben a même déjà
entre êtres humains on n'arrive pas à se
mettre d'accord sur ce que c'est de
l'intelligence est ce que c'est de la
vraie intelligence quoi donc maintenant
essayer de faire ça entre espèces ça va
être intéressant
voilà donc compliqué et je pense que ta
boîte et du doigt quelque chose de
fondamental c'est eu à parler justement
d'intelligence humaine et je crois que
on n'est pas vraiment équipe et a de
toute façon reconnaître une autre forme
d'intelligence que la nôtre ah non
j'ai utilisé le terme réfléchir parce
que bon c'est comme tu disais et c'est
l'intelligence humaine pour me serrer
fléchir pour les animaux c'est pas
forcément la même chose mais on
réfléchit pas de la même manière voilà
c'est typiquement ouais ouais bah c
c'est un peu l'éternel problème de
l'anthropocentrisme j'ai envie de dire
et de l'anthropomorphisme nation de d2
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
justement chez les autres espèces voilà
voilà donc en fait on n'arrive pas à
reconnaître une autre forme
d'intelligence que la nôtre et on
projette notre propre forme
d'intelligence sur les autres animaux
donc donc déjà le premier obstacle
cette discussion c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle
intelligent sacrebleu qu'est-ce qu'on
veut elle va rappeler à l'intelligence
donc je pense qu'il va falloir se
restreindre enfin je sais pas trop mais
on va peut-être falloir se restreindre
justement à cette forme d'intelligence
qu'on sait reconnaître et qui est la
nôtre
oui c'est une autre limitation on va
dire par défaut oui parce que tu vois là
un dauphin si ça se trouve les dauphins
ils sont super intelligent il ya des
articles qui disent qu'ils sont capables
d'avoir des conversations de résoudre
des problèmes et tout ça bah oui mais
ils ont comme ils ont pas de pouce
opposable et aucune expression faciale
bas on est quand même super embêté c'est
difficile et que le temps c'est quand
même des mammifères donc ils sont pas si
loin que ça de nous et là oui on parle
que de mammifères alors imagine
maintenant un truc genre pandora tout
c'est le cas il ya un réseau de racines
intelligents sous terre mais tu en voilà
comme de toute façon n'est pas connecté
à ce réseau et qu'on n'a aucune idée de
comment il fonctionne et comment ils
s'expriment
si même il s'exprime d'ailleurs ah oui
on reconnaîtra jamais sa com de
l'intelligence même si on l'a souvenait
quoi c'est ça marche même chez nous
imaginons que toutes les armes se
connecter par des racines yuko que ce
soit comment est ce qu'on fait pour
savoir que va ça ressemble à des
neurones et que ça interagir ensemble de
la même manière les signaux électriques
peut-être à la rigueur c'est à peu près
tout ce qu'on va pouvoir trouver
ouais voilà donc donc on va dire que
déjà que notre discussion à vient de
trouver une limite à ses fabuleuses
c'est que de toute façon on parle
d'intelligence semblable à la nôtre
et reconnaissable par ce qui fait que
l'espèce la plus intelligente
après nous ben s'est imposé voilà la
vidéo vous pouvez vous abonner l'achat
like
punchers la cloche tout ça non bon
tonique trente quatre minutes trente de
débat c'est formidable non oui bon voilà
l'espèce qui a le plus de chances de
développer une intelligence
anthropomorphique c7 chimpanzé après et
après le chimpanzé ce sera deux gorilles
et après le gorille s'est longtemps et
ainsi de suite
mais mais mais mais mais on sait bien ce
que vous voulez bande de petits filous
qui nous écoutent et on sait bien ce que
vous attendez de nous ce que vous voulez
ce que vous attendez nous c'est qu'on
discute de est ce que si les dinosaures
n'avait pas disparu est ce qu'il aurait
pu devenir intelligent comme nous du
coup on précise comme nous donc on parle
bien d'une intelligence comme nous pas
d'une intelligence autre que la nôtre
donc il ya quelqu'un qui soit capable
d'utiliser des outils voilà tout ça donc
pas typiquement cette image du trot dont
avec un gros cerveau la fin à l'époque
il appelait ça à sténo nico zaurus là
dans les années 70 l'image de ce trop
dont avec des gros yeux à un gros
cerveau etc
est-ce que ça c'est possible quoi en
gros donc là on est typiquement sur une
intelligence comme la nôtre c'est à dire
une intelligence accompagné d'un gros
cerveau parce que c'est pas forcément
une condition sinequanone au final si
vous avez un réseau neuronal extrêmement
efficace vous pouvez avoir une
intelligence avec un petit cerveau un
petit serveur où vous pouvez avoir plein
de petits cerveaux connectés les uns aux
autres ce serait la théorie pandora oui
c'est ça le plein de petits systèmes
nerveux connectés les uns aux autres
voire même plein de petits organismes
qui agissent chacun comme une cellule du
système nerveux mais bon bref donc on va
parler d'une intelligence comme la nôtre
donc un seul individu avec un gros
cerveau voilà
est-ce que ça c'est possible et c'est là
que je vais avoir besoin de toi et moi
mais parce que la grande experte en en
oiseau c'est quand même toit et oui mais
alors c'est sûr que des dinosaures au
final on ne sait pas vraiment si eux ils
avaient une certaine sorte
d'intelligence ou pas mais par contre ce
qu'on sait c'est que leurs descendants
des oiseaux actuels eux dans certains
groupes en tout cas parce que c'est sûr
que vous regardez une autruche on va se
demander si c'est intelligent ou pas le
bestiau mais si vous regardez des
groupes comme ceux des perroquets ou des
corbeaux tout simplement baala vous avez
des oiseaux qui sont un peu plus
intelligent beaucoup plus intelligent
d'ailleurs pour certains qui sont
capables d'utiliser des outils qui
construisent des trucs absolument
incroyable dans le cas de certains de
certains passereaux qui construisent des
nids on se demande comment ils font avec
juste un bec et des pâtes
donc là on est quand même sur un niveau
d'intelligence qui happe avoisine celui
des primes entend venir
oui alors range ton commentaire tout de
suite
non mais je le vois là il est là en
train d'écrire dinosaures non aviens je
le vois donc rocheteau commentaires sur
des dinosaures oui évidemment que quand
il à dire dinosaures on va dire on va
parler de dinosaures non aviens on nous
sommes au courant que les oiseaux sont
des dinosaures
merci donc évidemment qu'on va faire une
opposition entre dinosaures non aviens
et oiseaux et on va appeler les
dinosaures non aviens des dinosaures for
the sick of simplicity voilà c'est un
peu plus court comme donc c'est bon tu
peux leur emballé on est d'accord
ouais donc l'intelligence donc oui les
dinosaures déjà ils ont survécu ils ont
donné les oiseaux mais évidemment ça
répond toujours pas à la question est ce
que les dinosaures aurait pu devenir
intelligent et ça y répond en fait et ça
y répond pas c'est ça le problème c'est
les dinosaures il aurait pu devenir
intelligent s'il avait survécu
puisqu'ils ont survécu et que certains
d'entre eux sont devenus extrêmement
intelligent au point de résoudre des
problèmes
des problèmes de qui sont équivalents à
ce qu'un enfant de quel âge peut
résoudre ça dépend des espèces va aller
jusqu'à cinq ans pour certains perroquet
donc voilà ça avait quand même des
perroquets capable de résoudre des trucs
un enfant de 6 ans cinq ans mail envoyé
quatre cinq ans ça dépend le truc avec
la question de l'intelligence c'est
aussi le conte est un peu obligé enfin
quand on parle d'intelligence dans un
contexte évolutif on est un peu obligé
de résumer sa taille du cerveau aussi
oui parce que le problème c'est qu'on a
pas les comportements oui fossilisation
des comportements et malheureusement
l'intelligence on peut surtout
l'associer à des comportements parce qu
on a en a tendance à dire par exemple
que les drom et aux or donc la famille
des raptor ils sont trés ils étaient
très intelligents qu'ils étaient déjà il
avait un plus gros cerveau que la
plupart des autres dinosaures ce qui est
vrai mais ce qui n'a toujours pas la
taille du cerveau des oiseaux il avait
alors on leur attribue un comportement
de chasse en meute mais alors ça ça
s'est très mal et très débattue c'est
très débattue jeunes aiment tout ce
qu'on a trouvé c'est finalement dès
drôme et aux orres fossilisés autour
d'un ordre aux orres quoi donc c'est pas
non plus oui et quelques empreintes qui
associe deux ou trois individus quoi
donc éventuellement ils pouvaient se
trimballer se promener plus plus que 1
voilà en groupe
l on voit des petits groupes mais voilà
à chasser en meute c'est quand même un
comportement qu'on peut difficilement
extraire des fossiles coin à moins
d'avoir ce qu'on a découvert récemment
pour homo sapiens des traces
justement d'empreintes de pas d'homo
sapiens est en train de suivre du gibier
jusqu'à la trace où on le voit la battre
et ça c'est quelque chose ça fond les
dix yonnaise oui ça c'est déjà
exceptionnel de le trouver pour me
sapiens l'animal en question je crois
que c'était un pari ce géant donc
c'était en amérique du nord est mais
voilà le gta c'est déjà exceptionnel de
trouver ça pour homo sapiens a retrouvé
sa pour des dromes est aux ordres c'est
mais c'est le seul moyen de le démontrer
qu'il chasser en meute c'est de trouver
plein de traces de pattes de roméo szohr
qui sont très facilement identifiable
puisqu'elles ont que deux doigts vu
qu'ils ont la griffe relevé
donc ça à la limite l'attribution à
drôme et aux orres serait pas compliqué
mais par contre vrai il faut trouver une
trace ou tu vois plusieurs individus
déjà qu'ils marchent ensemble et qui
ensuite au bout de la piste
tu vois la trace de la tacc voilà tout
réussir à reconnaître une trace d'attac
aussi ça va être la taxe suffisamment
reconnaissable pour qu'on puisse en
faire quelque chose parce que si c'est
juste un gros fouillé caisses sont
marchés dessus je ne sais quoi ça va
être là c'est quasiment impossible
donc voilà donc on leur attribue ce
comportement de chasse en meute et même
là honnêtement je suis pas sûr je suis
pas sûr à 100% et et le débat est en
cours il ya eu au moins deux ou trois
articles publiés sur les dix dernières
années à propos de ça ce qui est
beaucoup
je sais que ça a pas l'air mais c'est
beaucoup ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une
controverse
voilà et puis il ya ce fameux cette
fameuse ce fameux problème des pièges à
prédateurs qui ont tendance à pied j'ai
plein de prédateurs autour d'une proie
mais seulement parce que la proie était
coincé dans de la boue par exemple et
que les prédateurs se sont aussi en
lisez dans la boue donc les pièges à
prédateur c'est un processus taphonomie
qu donc un processus du début de la
fossilisation va dire qui peut
facilement faire penser qu'une espèce
donnée pouvait chasser en meute alors
qu'en fait ils se sont juste retrouver
tous coincés là parce qu'ils ont été
attirés par là-même proie et on a les
crocodiles qui dont on peut croire
qu'ils chassent en meute alors qu'en
réalité sont juste après la même proie
sédition juste à côté en fait c'est
juste qu'ils sont dans la même rivière
voilà ma rivière et ayew qui pas si un
crocodile si sûr qu'il tarde à le tuer
qui tarde à tuer ce look il a chopé du
coup les autres crocodiles viennent
entre guillemets l'aider mais en fait
non non il s'arrache chacun un morceau
ils veulent juste leur part du gâteau
c'est tout c'est ça c'est trop facile
allez tiens tu l'as déjà tué à moitié
mais je fais pas piqué des six appareils
mais là on s'éloigne des arcs aux ormes
c'est un peu pareil pour les varans de
komodo c'est c'est plus de
l'opportunisme en fait que la chasse en
groupe
donc voilà vous avez dit vous avez 50
nuance de chasse en groupe des milliards
de nuances d'intelligence et au milieu
de tout ça pour arriver à dire si des
espèces qui sont complètement éteinte
avait des comportements spéciaux à
partir des fossiles donc la taille du
servir pour en revenir là c'est le
premier indice et après vous avez
quelques fossiles des fois qu'ils sont
miraculeusement préservée de
d'empreintes de comportement enfin après
ces fossiles par exemple ces animaux qui
sont fossilisés sur le nil
on retrouve les eaux de la même espèce
typiquement avec les soins parentaux que
ça peut être des fois des comportements
fossilisés mais c'est vrai qu'à part ça
déjà il ya au moins des trucs qu'on peut
éliminer les sauropodes par exemple
clairement l'intelligence s'était pas
leurs rayons non non on est au niveau de
l'autre mais c'est pas mais c'est pas
pour être médisant là il ya un truc il
faut comprendre et je crois qu'on aurait
peut-être presque même dû commencer par
ça mais on n'est qu'à 15 minutes mais on
aurait dû commencer par ça
l'intelligence c'est pas une fin en soi
c'est pas parce que vous êtes
intelligent que vous êtes supérieur à
qui que ce soit ou à quoi que ce soit
l'intelligence elle s'est développée
chez l'homme parce que l'homme
il est un poil dans la nature il vaut
rien il en a besoin pour survivre voilà
on n'a pas de griffes on n'a pas de
crocs on n'a pas de d'énormes canine
l'homme s'il n'a pas son intelligence
pour fabriquer des outils pour s'adapter
pour adapter son comportement aux
situations il a zéro instinct pour le
reste il n'a pas d'instinct il n'a pas
de croo il a pas de griffes il peut rien
faire pour se reproduire on a de la star
et x sur des noms mais voilà on n'a pas
de en a pas on a pu les réflexes en fait
mais parce que on a justement cette
adaptation comportementale notre
comportement nous fait nous adapter aux
situations ont fait pas du feu par
instinct non par exemple non c'est de
l'apprentissage y voilà c'est de
l'apprentissage ans tu as dit fais toi
fais toi un feu pour se réchauffer tu
sais que pour te réchauffer le meilleur
moyen c'est de faire un feu et de
couvrir le premier truc que tu fais
quand tu te retrouves à poil dans la
jungle c'est du cash et des vêtements
courts et tu fais un peu voilà et puis
au bout d'un moment tu fini par
apprendre l'hygiène voilà tu le fais un
coin pour kaka si tu survis jusque là
mais voilà là l'intelligence n'est pas
une fin en soi l'homme est devenu
intelligent
l'homme descend des australopithèques
qui étaient herbivores
enfin omnivore à tendance plutôt
herbivores ouais et tous les primates
étaient soit herbivores sont omnivores
attendant ces herbivores quoi tous les
primates ont toujours été dans cette
voie là et l'homme homo sapiens enfin au
mot le genre homo pardon les premiers
homo donc homo habilis erectus on sait
pas trop où ça s'est produit mais aux
alentours de habilis erectus l'homme
s'est mis à bouffer de la viande est
alors c'est pas les protéines de la
viande qui lui ont alimenté son cerveau
c'est juste le fait que cette adaptation
un régime alimentaire carnet ça du coup
obligé l'homme à devoir fabriquer des
outils pour pouvoir chasser
parce que l avantage des plantes c'est
que on est très bien équipé pour aller
bouffer les plantes sa demande juste
certaines dents et donc pas plus évident
que la moyenne et puis c'est tout voilà
les australopithèques us les avais déjà
donc australopithecus il avait déjà tout
ce qu'il fallait pour bouffer des
plantes ne s'était pas le problème et
quelques petits quelques petits résidus
carnet des petits vertébrés
voilà des insectes est actuellement des
yeux voilà s'il en trouvait mais voilà
et c'est juste qu'à un moment où il ya
eu une division en fait chez
australopithecus bon pour faire super
simple mais voilà j'avais dit il ya une
division il ya des parentes robe qui
sont partis dans la voix super herbivore
donc ils sont devenus ce qu'on appelle
les casse noix les ils ont un énorme
crâne avec des énormes muscles et avec
des énormes dans pts 5e en dit plus sur
ce truc là
voilà c'est vraiment une anatomie qui
est fait pour défoncer de la végétation
quoi laisser pas essayer pas de casser
les noix avec les dents vous vraiment
bonne idée ça ou cassés les dents c'est
pas la peau c'est pas bon donc
de l'autre côté donc du coup en même
temps il ya eu au mot le genre homo qui
lui s'est spécialisée plus vers une
nourriture omnivore attendant ce carnet
et du coup ce et c'est là que justement
cette scission a eu lieu donc c'est ce
qu'on appelle une partition de niche les
niches écologiques ont été partagées par
les hominidés d'un côté les herbivores
avec part entre hop et de l'autre côté
au mot et donc c'est parce qu'ils
s'adaptent et un régime carné c'est
parce qu'il était en concurrence avec
les australopithèques et les
australopithèques qui était plus harbour
et les parents troc qui était encore
plus herbivore que homo s'est réfugié on
va dire dans cette danse est
investisseurs que son pays aurait besoin
de changer le régime alimentaire au
final il aurait pas eu cette concurrence
il y avait pas besoin de devenir plus
carnivore mais là du coup comme il s'en
retrouver poussé par la baballe à ils
sont enfin on avait ces deux organes
qu'on appelle des mains et qui servait à
rien en gros et six attrapés du truc
ouais ben voilà servaient à attraper
détruits qui va en attraper des outils
on s'est mis à les taper les uns sur les
autres
alors je sais pas comment ça s'est
produit mais apparemment d'après les
outils en gros on a commencé par des
trucs très très rudimentaire quoi on a
cassé des pierres en deux ça faisait un
petit tranchant et basta quoi mais voilà
c'est le grosso modo le fait de
l'intelligence de homo est venue après
le fait qu'il soit devenu carnivores
voilà et d'être équipé sur tout et du
coup cet équipement il a fallu qu on le
fabrique ce qui a stimulé l'évolution de
l'intelligence
voilà donc fabriquer des outils pour
pouvoir chasser et ce qui a ensuite
stimuler les volumes
du cerveau c'est pour ça qu'il ya un lag
entre le moment où de l'apparition du
genre homo et là l'augmentation de la
taille du cerveau on va dire
l'augmentation de la taille du cerveau
ces homo erectus alors que le genre homo
il existe depuis au moins habiles ea
s'est probablement même avant ça donc
donc voilà c'est l'intelligence c'est
pas une fin en soi
chez l'homme l'intelligence c'est un
outil de survie c'est une adaptation
l'intelligence et physiologiquement
extrêmement coûteuse de cerveau c'est un
quart de notre consommation d'énergie je
crois que c'est un truc de livres quoi
le cerveau c'est un truc de ouf parce
que tout ce paquet neurones à sa bouche
bée énormément ça bouffe énormément donc
l'intelligence et c'est pas une fin en
soi devenir intelligent c'est pas c'est
pas un luxe c'est une nécessité c'est si
et seulement si vous y êtes obligés et
donc j'en reviens aux dinosaures
les sauropodes qui s'emballait qu ils
sont vigilants c'est l'art simple un
simple mouvement de sauropodes contre un
prédateur défonce le prédateur même sans
qu'il l'ait voulu envers la patrie c'est
fini voilà il te bouscule têtu voilà
quinze mètres tu es mort donc voilà le
sort aux potes c'est clairement pas sa
voie et on va revenir donc au trot donc
le troodon avait t-il le moindre intérêt
à devenir intelligent il était pas si
grand que ça c'est vrai il est pas
grands parce qu'ils mangent des insectes
des petits vertébrés des invertébrés
enfin voila un petit truc c'est qu'il
est assez opportuniste finalement qu'est
ce qu'il a vraiment besoin
d'intelligence pour ça ça je veux pas
m'avancer sur l'opportunisme des
troubles mais par contre on peut parler
de son équipement terrain de 3 ans dont
c'était quand même un drôle mais enfin
il est quand même proche de raptor et
c'est donc il a quand même cette petite
griffe l'a bien bien il vient effacer
les gains courbé sur cinq types y est là
il ya quand même des petits bras bien
gris fut aussi des petites dents enfin
je veux dire le trot dont il est équipé
pour chasser ce qu'il a besoin de
chasser quoi c'est ça il a hélas ce
qu'il faut où il faut pourchasser alors
est-ce qu'il a besoin de devenir
intelligent pour moi la réponse est
clairement non
et est-ce que 6 1
un membre de la famille des drôme et aux
au rider avait survécu à la crise
crétacé tertiaire
donc sachant que l'on part du principe
que les oiseaux ne sont pas considérés
comme des drôme et aux orres idée parce
que il ya certaines phylogénie qui place
les oiseaux parmi les roméo zoo rider il
y en a une qui était sorti il ya pas
longtemps mais bref je vais pas m'égarer
on va dire que les oiseaux c'est le
groupe frère dé drôme et aux rides et
donc les deux sont séparés s'il ya drôme
et aux oreilles des qui avaient survécu
est ce qu'il aurait eu le moindre
intérêt à devenir intelligent à mon avis
sinon non si les légères occupé pour
vous y retirer ja équipés pour pour son
régime alimentaire je vois pas l'intérêt
donc ouais voilà un côté de ça tous les
autres dinosaures enfin je veux dire les
du côté des carnot szohr des gros
prédateurs de manière générale de toute
façon c'est pareil ce serait bien ont
ils ont ce qu'il faut où il faut qu il
est du côté des herbivores maintenant
des arts need is tient de toute façon
j'ai envie de dire l'intelligence c'est
pas tellement du côté des herbivores
qu'on va la trouver mais mais mais il ya
les éléphants les éléphants ils sont
bien intelligent et complètement
herbivore d'ailleurs ils foutent tout
par terre en matière de tous les gens
qui disent justement que c'est
l'adaptation en régime carné qui a
apporté les protéines nécessaires au
développement du cerveau non le cerveau
il a besoin de sucre complètement donc
le régime carné et pas forcément une
condition sinequanone là ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est parce que il
fallait des outils pour pouvoir chasser
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas
développer une intelligence avec un
régime herbivores la preuve les
éléphants qui sont extrêmement
intelligents qui ont un cerveau alors
qui est un petit peu plus gros que la
moyenne mais qui n'est pas si gros que
ça mais par contre ils ont des
comportements assez sont capables de se
reconnaître dans le miroir dans la
mesure où on arrive à les équiper comme
il faut parce que les éléphants ont une
vue qui est pas bonne du tout oui qu'il
faut il faut leur fils et le diable à
ses proches faufiler un miroir bien-être
super grossissant
et tout ça tout ça mais voilà ils sont
capables de se reconnaître dedans ils
ont ils sont capables d'identifier leurs
morts et ils font des espèces de
procession avec leur mort moi ce genre
de cérémonie où quelque sorte file en
l'air encore finie c'est vrai que c'est
juste de l'observation gars m'ont dit
c'est de l'éthologie on n'est pas sûr de
ce qui se passe on anthropomorphisme et
comme on l'a dit au début on est obligé
voilà on est obligé on essaye de
reconnaître une intelligence comparable
à l'homme dans ses détails du cerveau
ces comportements assimilables à des
comportements humains
voilà et les éléphants ils ont une
mémoire de ouf notamment une mémoire
olfactive
ils sont capables de reconnaître les
sessions des centaines d'individus rien
qu'à l'odeur ils sont capables de se
souvenir aussi d2 où se trouvent les
points d'eau dans la savane alors que
ward et points d'eau dans la savane y en
a pas beaucoup et ils sont loin mais
plusieurs coeurs généralement donc ils
sont vraiment ils ont ils ont quand même
une intelligence qui est très très
comparable à la nôtre avec un régime
herbivores et il ya des éléphants qui
ont eu un cerveau comparable au moins à
la taille du cerveau chez homo habilis
voire les plus les premiers homo erectus
quoi donc cédé et les phares éteints
mais il y en a eu donc donc c'est quand
même c'est quand même une ligne est
qu'il faut pas négliger je pense les
éléphants et pour le coup pour le coup
eux ils ont ce qu'il faut pour fabriquer
des outils ils ont la trouille
ils s'en servent et sincère très très
bien et ça faire pas mal de choses avec
d'ailleurs c'est incroyable ce qu'ils
peuvent apprendre ans en arrière dans
l'air
ils sont très doux avec des sons très
très doux avec la trompe c'est
impressionnant la manière dont ça peut
bouger en fait c'est c'est pas aussi
aussi précis que nos doigts
c'est sûr on va pas se cacher que c'est
pas c'est pas des doigts mais ils sont
quand même capable d'attraper des trucs
qui sont très fragiles
rien qu'avec leurs troupes sans avoir de
problèmes au final c'est assez
impressionnant et là où la wii une
comparaison intéressante à faire du coup
c'est justement le donc en repartant du
principe qu'on cherche une intelligence
humaine et que l'intelligence humaine
elle vient du fait qu'on a développé des
outils et qu'on avait justement
des organes qui ne servait à rien du
fait qu'on était bipède on avait ces
deux organes qui étaient des mâles qui
était libre et qui pouvait être utilisé
pour fabriquer les outils justement
encore une fois on peut repartir sur les
oiseaux les oiseaux ils ont un gros
problème au niveau du développement de
l'intelligence c'est qu'ils ont des
ailes c'est qu'ils ont les ailes voilà
donc qui sont pas de bras ils ont pas de
barra et donc et c'est pas un problème
en soi je veux dire on peut être
intelligent sans avoir de pouce
opposable commencez pas à partir sur le
délire du pouce opposable sérieusement
mais voilà non parce que je vous connais
j'en ai vu des commentaires comme ça
délire de pouce à l on peut pas être
intelligence en plus auprès d'abc on
sait on peut qu'on vient de dire que les
éléphants ils sont très intelligents ils
ont pas de pulsions connais alors est-ce
que le l'espèce de douane sur la tronche
ça compte comme un plus opposable bas
ils ont une capacité de l'appréhension
ces salles est comparable à notre pouce
mais je veux dire ils peuvent être un
peu c'est juste que c'est pas voilà les
oiseaux le problème c'est que ils
utilisent ils utilisent deux organes
pour attraper des trucs et pour
fabriquer des choses et il arrive à
fabriquer de choses remarquables tu
parlais des ni lait ni tisserin son sont
des objets on n'est pas capable de faire
sa mue et on serait capable de l'eiti
sévit va falloir quand même à prendre
pendant mais c'est quand même pas mal
d'heures voilà quelque chose mais là
pour le coup c'est de l'instinct en plus
c'est à dire qu'ils apprennent jamais si
parce que les premiers ni qu'ils font en
fait bon ça commence par de l'instinct
mais après petit attise perfectionne
d'accord les premiers ni voilà ils sont
pas géniaux géniaux généralement ben
ouais donc voilà les oiseaux ils sont
capables de fabriquer des choses
d'attraper des objets les corbeaux ils
sont capables de manipuler des objets
comme on disait au point de pouvoir
résoudre certains certaines petits
problèmes qu'on leur pose des petits
problèmes mécaniques
ils sont capables d'en créer les
ateliers aussi sont capables de créer de
manufactures et des objets relativement
simple mais quand même des petits bâtons
des choses comme ça
même une espèce de corbeaux qui est
assez impressionnant qui découpe une
feuille alors sur le bord de la feuille
en feuilleter des petits crochets et des
couples bord de la feuille juste de la
bonne taille ça lui fait une sorte de
petit bateau avait décroché sur le côté
qui permet en fait d'aller piocher dans
un trou dans 2 les corses une petite
larme qui à l'intérieur et de la
remontée grâce au crochet en question et
ça c'est quand même assez incroyable
parce que du coup ils découpent la
feuille juste de la bonne taille pour
rentrer dans le trou et pour cocher cet
écart à la chaussée quand même assez
incroyable comme comme comportement et
tout ça avec des seins macchabées voilà
1500 mah avec un bec et dessert est
justement le problème
enfin l'obstacle que je pourrai voir
justement à un développement d'une
intelligence similaire à l'homme donc
associé à une capacité de prévention de
fabriquer des outils et tout ça c'est
que justement bas le bec
il a d'autre fonction que la sélection
naturelle doit maintenir
oui ben brick lane ont mangé le bec il
est surtout fait pour manger rattraper
des proies et voilà c'est donc si le bec
se spécialise pour une fonction de pour
fabriquer des outils il peut plus il va
moins bien servir sa fonction primaire
qui est de manger et du coup la
sélection naturelle dans paris mais ça
du tout s'est passé très caricatural
évidemment mais vous voyez où je veux en
venir
et pareil pour les serres les serres
c'est avant tout un organe de locomotion
bon même là la limite il y aurait un peu
plus de souplesse mais on est bien
d'accord qui peuvent pas lever leurs
deux pattes en même temps alors après il
ya 17 e
je sais pas parce qu'après des espèces
d'oiseaux mais alors celle là sont
généralement super spécialisé dans le
vol typiquement les martinez et les
hirondelles qui en fait on des pas très
réduite qui ne leur servent qu'à
s'accrocher
ils peuvent pas vraiment se déplacer
avec donc les pâtes sont vraiment
superbes buts alors à la rigueur on
pourrait supposer que peut-être dans une
espèce d'oiseau comme ça ou les pâtes
finalement ne sort plus vraiment à la
locomotion pourrait peut-être y avoir un
développement différentes des packs pour
agen paix des trucs je laisse le temps
aux gens de s'imaginer le petit martin
et avec deux silex en train de les
tailler en volant être un détail et avec
ses pieds pendant qu avec ses petits
bras y plane
là pour le coup de trop de l'hirondelle
et du martinet c'est qu'ils sont déjà
tellement spécialisée dans leur niche
écologique c'est faut voir quand même
les ailes que ça soit reclassé un
véritable avion de chasse au final ils
sont déjà tellement spécialisés que je
suis pas certaine qu'ils pourraient se
développer dans une autre voie enfin
c'est toujours possible mais là ça va
être un peu compliqué bon on peut en
revenir du coup à trop donc donc le
fameux troodon est ce qu'il pourrait
devenir intelligent donc oui en
l'occurrence il avait ce qu'il fallait
contrairement aux oiseaux lui il avait
des bras il y avait des bras mais il
avait natura il était bipède donc a
priori et en a plusieurs cas d'évolution
chez les théropodes de réduction des
chais théropodes parents de réduction
des bras qui montre que les bras c'était
quand même pas si crucial que ça chez
ces bestioles l'armée alors attention
parce que ce n'était pas les théropodes
les plus grands jeux et qu'elle est chez
lesquels les princes réduisez ou alors
c'était noria les alvarezsauridés qui
sont pas bien grave qui ont aussi les
bras très réduit non mais c'est pas
spécialement les grands c'est plus basse
et plus souvent chez les grands parce
qu'on a des exemples da belize au rider
et des tyrannosauridés évidemment
simplement
mais non les alvarezsauridés c'est des
petits théropodes qui avait pas de barre
à non plus et puis il ya les bons je
sais pas mais après vous êtes à le
contre-exemple de microraptor par
exemple qui était possiblement
arboricole et là par contre les bras a
été super trippant fiable bien développé
donc tu as les deux possibilités mais
dis donc voilà on sait que chez les
théropodes il ya des exemples
de de réduction des bras donc les bras
était pas cruciaux pour la survie donc
possiblement on sait que c'est
possiblement un organe qui est libre et
on a le pouce qui est semi opposable
chez c'était mon pote donc une peau
capacité de saisie de précisions c'est
un d'ailleurs des des gros arguments en
faveur du fameux la théorie du steve
downie cause de rhuys intelligent qui
dit que voilà le pouce opposable du coup
a évolué à partir du du doigt un des
théropodes remet alors attention parce
que peut-être que tous les théropodes
sont pas arboricole et qu'ils
utilisaient pas forcément à leurs bras
pour grimper aux arbres mais il y en a
certains qui devait quand même utiliser
les bras pour d'autres choses
typiquement la reproduction
ici jamais étape les bras et paya puis
de rentrer aux puits qui maintient les
actionnaires mais là on parle pas de
faire d'eux les bras non mais c'est pas
une question de perdre les bras de la
perte des brassées juste l'argument que
j'utilise pour dire les bras ils sont
libres globalement les bras sont libres
pour adopter une nouvelle fonction si on
applique une sélection naturelle vers
une évolution d'une capacité à tailler
des outils alors ça va pas ça va pas ça
va pas empêcher une autre fonction de
s'accomplir
voilà c'est ça que je veux dire ça
dépend des fois parce que s'il ya une
fonction très précises peut-être que
t'as pas forcément il met justement en
argument c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
fonctions très précises bon bah on va
partir du principe pas de fonctions très
précises et que du coup le possible
voilà donc trop dont on aurait pu avoir
cette ce pouce opposable qui lui aura
permis d'attraper les outils et de les
tailler et 2 d'obtenir une intelligence
simili humaine mais encore une fois
pourquoi taille et des outils si tu as
déjà les outils pour pour attaquer t3
faut pas trop l'intérêt pourquoi
pourquoi tu t'en mettrait à tailler un
silex en bout pointu alors que tu as
déjà tous les bouts pointus qu'il faut
partout il faut quoi ça gré à gré des
bonnes dents alors à moins que justement
les troodon alors et l'a peut-être
éventuellement il faut
à bord d une chose qu'on n'a pas abordé
jusqu'à présent c'est la théorie qui dit
que l'intelligence peut aussi évoluer
comme un effet secondaire d'autres
choses et donc en l'occurrence c'est
alors par exemple la théorie du social
brain donc du cerveau social c'est à
dire que les animaux dakar vivant en
société pour se protéger enfin vivent en
groupe pour se protéger avant tout
doivent doivent gérer des relations
sociales qui n'existait pas avant
et du coup deviennent plus intelligents
enfin du coup la sélection naturelle se
met à sélectionner des comportements
plus intelligents les comportements
sociaux typiquement voilà des
comportements qui sont plus en plus
sociaux parce que ça permet de mieux
survivre dans le groupe
voilà ça permet de mieux s'intégrer au
groupe du coup tu vas tu développes des
capacités de neurones miroirs malade tu
apprends à lire les expressions des
autres tu apprends à anticiper les
réactions des autres et tout ça ça
stimule le cerveau et la sélection
naturelle sélectionne positivement les
cerveaux qui gère le mieux ce genre de
choses là du coup le voilà oui dans
quelle heure donc le cerle un gros
cerveau ça peut aussi être un effet
secondaire enfin un gros cerveau une
forte intelligente ça peut aussi être un
effet secondaire est donc là dans le cas
de deux du trot donc peut-être que
justement l'intelligence viendrait de
quelque chose d'autre
tu fais qui vivait en groupe ou
peut-être est-ce qu'on en sait rien au
final
et puis alors les fossiles de trop dont
on en a pas des blocs ouais bon c'est
voilà on a suffisamment de fossiles pour
dire qu'il est qu'ils couvaient c'est
eux alors qu'ils vivaient en groupe en
disons qu'on les trouve rarement tout
seul on va dire les trous aux dons de là
à dire qu'il est en groupe
après un autre comportement possible
pour les carnivores c'est simplement il
ya un peu de soins parentaux c'est à
dire que si jamais il couvre ses yeux il
est fort possible chez les carnivores ça
paraît normal que ba la mère ou le père
ou les deux apprennent tout simplement à
chasser au petit et dans ce cas là on a
comme chez les tigres actuelle départ
des petits qui vont rester avec la mer
pendant un an deux ans et puis après une
fois qu'ils sont adultes et
naturellement il faut rechercher leur
territoire
après ça a peu de chances d'être le cas
quand même est ce que les amis les
oiseaux les oiseaux les plus bazzo donc
les plus proches entre guillemets du
dinosaure des dinosaures non aviens
c'est les autruches et les anatidés les
anaty forme les canards mais eux ils
restent avec les parents pendant un
moment
ouais mais pas si longtemps que ça quand
ils sont quelques mois mais il faut dire
aussi que les hauts gradés super vite
voilà alors c'est sûr il ya un seul
plaisir au roi des super yachts mais il
est possible que du coup les théropodes
qu'on ait retour dans le groupe ce soit
simplement des petits qu était quasiment
taille adulte mais encore avec la mer ou
qui que ce soit qui prenait soin d'eux
et après on a des oiseaux qui reste en
groupe alors il n'a pas beaucoup mais il
ya une espèce qui chassent en groupe qui
en l'occurrence la buse de harris ou là
le petit de l'an passé va rester avec
les parents pour aider à élever les
petits de l'année suivante alors c'est
un comportement très spécialisés et
c'est la seule espèce d'oiseaux qu'on
connaît d'oiseaux chasseurs en tout cas
qui fait ça mais ça existe
en parlant des buses de harris justement
on parlait de de chasser en meute mais
chasser en meute c'est quand même un
truc de mammifères sa part la buse de
harris il ya quelques laquelle à causeur
d'ailleurs de manière générale qu'on
sait qu'ils chassent en groupe
la très honnêtement chédozeau je crois
que la buse de harris est le seul cas de
d'oiseaux kesha son groupe donc c'est un
comportement qui est quand même hyper
rare chez les archosaures chance et a
pas mal de mammifères qui le font c'est
vrai mais les oiseaux non il n'ya même
pas tant de mammifères que savaient les
grands carnivores des fois c'est pareil
avec les petits où ils peuvent un peu
chasser en groupe
ouais mais c'est tout après les lions et
loup est un truc intéressant avec les
dauphins scellé c'est l'hypothèse de la
thermorégulation donc il ya des
chercheurs qui ont fait l'hypothèse que
donc les dauphins a été intelligent et
que c'est parce qu'ils ont un gros
cerveau etc etc etc
et il ya d'autres chercheurs qui ont
rajouté par dessus oui mais alors
l'intelligence n'est pas une fin en soi
encore une fois et peut-être qu'en fait
le gros cerveau il n'est là que pour la
thermorégulation à la base
l'intelligence année ça encore une fois
l'intelligence n'étant qu'une
conséquence
d'une autre fonction oui voilà un effet
secondaire on va dire de les aimer fille
qui se compte c'est le deuxième effet
qu'il est cool
en fait le gros cerveau n'est là que
parce que le cerveau c'est un organe
comme on disait qu'il extrêmement
coûteux physiologiquement donc en avoir
un gros ça veut dire produire énormément
de chaleur et quand tu vis dans l'eau
comme un dauphin
est-ce que doublé chez les baleines
normalement le cerveau est assez gros
sinon bah oui oui je les dauphins chez
les baleines
après des baleines après sont elles ont
un cerveau par rapport à la taille du
corps qui est gros que ça au final
j'imagine que ça dépend des espèces oui
ça dépend de la taille de l'espèce aussi
enfin pour ce qu'on en sait pour ce
qu'on arrive à l'identifier ils ont
l'air intelligent
oui mais peut-être que ce serait juste
donc le deuxième effet kiss cool du fait
qu'ils utilisent leur cerveau pour ce
qu'elles chauffent fait quoi à la base
et du coup ils ont ils ont un gros
cerveau qui leur sert à se réchauffer et
le gros cerveau a fini par produire de
l'intelligence parce qu'il est là voilà
donc et ça c'est une théorie qui est
quand même assez intéressante je trouve
parce que déjà c'est assez provocative
enfin je veux dire les dauphins les gens
ou une attache émotionnel assez
particulière aux dauphins et du tout
dire qu'à la base ils sont intelligents
mais c'est une erreur
c'est général de ces mamans ça a
déclenché des réactions assez
épidermique et du coup c'est très drôle
anthropologiquement parlant on va dire
mais voilà il ya le
il ya ce côté où l intelligence pourrait
n'être qu'un effet secondaire est donc
dans le débat sur les dinosaures à sang
chaud à sang froid encore une fois ça
mène
ça amène des question intéressante donc
les enfin petits théropodes comme trop
dont six proches des oiseaux il ya
quasiment aucun doute aujourd'hui qu'il
était qu'il était à sang chaud et du
coup est ce que dans un chai un petit
animal on sait que trop aux dons étaient
capables de vivre dans les latitudes
polaire on a retrouvé des troodon en
alaska
est ce qu'on sait s'ils avaient des
plumes oui il y avait des primes ouais
trop je veux dire même je suis pas sur
ses nerfs je vais mais je ne crois pas
qu'on ait trouvé de trop dont avec des
plumes mais je sais qu'on a retrouvé des
proches parents de trop dont en chine
d'accord parce que j'en ai jeté plus
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
je croyais et ses seins trop donc idée
qui a des plumes asymétrique je me
rappelle plus le nom pour le vol du coup
bas sur la queue seulement sur l'accusé
seulement voilà que le truc c'est que
les plumes asymétrique si les plumes de
vol typiquement va l'alléger
là il ya des plumes asymétrique mais que
sur l'accueil donc donc oui il ya se
lancer qu'il pouvait vivre dans les
dents les auteurs article donc pourquoi
pas imaginer un scénario où troodon
s'adaptant survivants dans les
survivants à l'extinction déjà enfin
survivants jusqu'à la fin du crétacé
parce que trop non c'est pas un truc du
crétacé de la fin du crétacé donc
survivants jusqu'à la fin du crétacé
puis au delà un truc à la troupe dont
qui survivraient dans les régions
polaires verrait son cerveau grossir
d'abord à des fins de thermorégulation
et finalement par incidence et par vit
en meute aussi pourquoi pas qui c'est
stimulée par la vie en meute on va dire
finirait par développer une intelligence
jusqu'aux poissons jusqu'au point où
finalement il se met à tailler des
outils même s'il en a aucun intérêt ça
on revient toujours on en revient
toujours à ça ce problème
se met à fabriquer des trucs voilà pour
bâtir se met à fabriquer des manteaux de
fourrure avec les mammifères tout
fraîchement évoluer déjà des primes ses
intérêts oui les mecs les plus de base
c'est pas pour le voilà on est d'accord
mais surtout chez trop demander l'aube
est donc le nom de fourrure mieux vaut
laisser tomber c'est le au couteau de
cuisine qui a gagné voilà bon il
fabrique pas des manteaux de fourrure il
fabrique pas des au couteau de cuisine
alors ils fabriquent quoi avec ses
petits doigts parce qu'il a quand même
son pouce opposable depuis le début il a
déjà comme l'a déjà la pousse la balle
esquisse fabriquerait pas à l'abri à la
rigueur pour se protéger des tempêtes et
barney gt2 comme ça parce qu'il a déplu
toi pourquoi l'homme se fait des
vêtements parce qu'il est à poil à la
rigueur certains animaux qui sont les
abris même s'ils ont de la foi ou déplu
c'est vrai j'ai croisé un terrier jamais
eu besoin de pouce opposable pour
creuser un terrier creuser un terrier
non mais construire autre chose par
exemple
ben on en vient aux primates il ya des
primates qui soit un niveau branchages
tous les soirs oui mais les oiseaux
savent faire béni saf faire des mises
ils n'ont pas de [ __ ] jouera peut-être
que dans un truc polaire et ben ils
auraient besoin demain pour poursuivre
un truc style igloo on sait pas ça
commence à devenir compliqué mais une
cabane de trappeur me vient le trône ou
à l'intérieur droit avec ça avec ça si
tu es s'appelle clash sa petite
casquette en queue de castor la neige à
l'est du québec bonjour surtout pas de
clichés et la chemise à carreaux on n'a
pas parlé sirop d'érable indésirables
ainsi donc le trône le troodon encore il
peut avoir un gros cerveau ça voilà la
dernière la dernière qu'on avait proposé
c'était avec les éléphants donc là c'est
notre article à nous qu'on a fait avec
paul longueur c'est pour les éléphants
ce qu'on avait proposé c'est que
il est possible aussi que l'un gros
cerveau évolue avec simplement avec la
taille du corps en fait il
il est un gros cerveau mais parce que en
fait l'heure d'abord il évolue vers de
grandes tailles et ensuite vers du
nanisme
donc en fait il serait d'abord grands
fans ils deviennent grands et du coup
leur cerveau grossi proportionnellement
à la taille du corps normal sauf
qu'après dans le cas d'un à nice mme tu
peux avoir une réduction du corps sans
réduction de la taille du cerveau ce
qu'est ce qui est arrivé chez les
éléphants
chez les éléphants nains de sicile par
exemple les éléphants n'a y avait plein
de deux lignes et d'éléphants n'a ils
ont plus ou moins secret en commun tous
ceux très en commun d'avoir justement un
cerveau qui est relativement plus grand
que le coc amerrissant sur une île le
troodon et n'était pas sur une wii alors
sa demande des conditions
exceptionnelles là on demande à trop
donc il y en a qui vit dans le cercle
polaire il grossit ceci dit et grossit
grossit dans le cercle polaire pourquoi
parce que le web bergman plus gros plus
du conserve tâche et leur tâche à leurs
skis et moins de surface que tu as moins
de six enfants est proportionnellement
donc aussi pour s'adapter et enfin pour
s'adapter
merci si on s'adapte en froid donc voilà
glaciaire oligocène donc 30 millions il
ya donc voilà trop on survit au crétacé
il se maintient dans les cercles
polaires mais il fait pas trop froid
encore à cette époque là au début du
cynodrome prof arrive l'oligocène
l'oligocène glacé glaciation donc là le
troodon il grossit adaptation au froid
ok ok ensuite la glaciation elle
s'arrête et là des les populations il ya
des populations de trop aux dons qui se
retrouvent perchés sur des îles qui
n'étaient pas des îles à ce moment là
ouais bah oui avec la glaciation il n'a
même pas désigné mais c'était quand même
beaucoup dit peut être qu'avec la
déglaciation pouf ça devient ça
redevient des îles hélas trop donc comme
un con il se retrouve coincé tailladé
population de trop d'eau qui comme des
cons se retrouve coincé ces populations
de trop dans la donc j'aurai vu les
dates peuvent être atteints de nanisme
insulaire parce que chez les carnivores
le nanisme insulaire c'est la réduction
2 enfin de la vie sur une île c'est
réduction des ressources drastique donc
généralement ya pas de carnivores d'asie
sympa en plus je sais pas s'il y avait
suffisamment petit pour avoir du nanisme
à sueur généralement ya pas de
carnivores s'il y en a eu il y avait
sept îles alors c'était quoi l'exemple
déjà c'était une île et des lapins
géants et des agglos géant je sais plus
et et lille deux faces et l'aigle de
deux armes de art truc du style mais du
coup là c'était un aigle géant je suis
plus hélas il était sur une île et au
lieu d'avoir une analyse mme insulaire
au contraire on avait plutôt du
gigantisme
ouais non c'est pas le mec le dommage ce
legs dont je parle celui qui chasse et
des mots à ceci dit c'est encore de
serge delassus maire de la super aussi
mais ouais mais là du coup donc il est
fort possible que ça évolue aussi dans
votre sens
oui mais ça ne nous arrange pas pour
notre scénario de mon point de vue c'est
dans nos cordes à ce qui t'arrange
locker bah oui ce qu'on veut c'est
arrivé à un scénario notre trop dont il
finit avec la considère ça semble mal
barré
donc froid polaire adaptation
augmentation de taille régression de la
glace isolement sur une île nanisme as
eu l'air est pur il n'y avait qu'un trop
non en admettant qu'il qu'il qu'il suive
la même processus évolutif que les
éléphants en sicile au fini avec à trop
long avec un gros cerveau pas forcément
intelligent parce que l'éléphant
d'annecy si l'on n'a aucune trace qu'il
était particulièrement intelligent non
ils étaient juste avec un peu grossière
il avait juste un gros cerveau n'est
même pas arrivée répond on n'est
toujours pas arrivée au point où trop
dont va utiliser ces [ __ ] de pouce
opposable qui ont l'impression qu'on
n'est pas sorti non je pense que là déjà
on a bien fait le
le tour des scénarios possibles la
meilleure chance pour trop aux dons
d'avoir un gros cerveau enfin de finir
intelligence et part et le deuxième
effet kiss cool c'est ça il avait pas il
a aucun intérêt immédiat devenir
intelligent trop dense et ça on est donc
la seule chance c'est qu'il développe
une intelligence par effets secondaires
c'est eva il est mal barré et on a
complètement oublié de parler des
poulpes parce que les plus justes la ba
oui mais quand on parle évidemment de
taille le cerveau parce que tout ce
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent cette taille
du cerveau et intelligence mais c'est
valable toit des tétrapodes mais c'est
valable que pour les tétrapodes parce
qu'au final les poules ils sont ils sont
très très très intelligent qui sera
encore une fois unanimes jose calif
pieuvre tout ça ils sont capables de
réseauter problèmes en fin d'épreuve
donc ils sont capables de montrer une
intelligence que nous sommes capables de
reconnaître en tant que tel c'est hors
du commun pour assez hors du commun dans
le gros problème des poulpes c'est
qu'ils auraient du mal à devenir hyper
intelligent parce qu'ils vivent jusqu'à
la reproduction et après ils profitent
tous voilà donc imaginer sa vie 2 encore
plus de moi une fois ça dépend des
espèces
mais selon les espèces mais en gros il
se laisse crever après la reproduction
donc c'est un peu dommage
donc ils auront du mal le problème c'est
que du coup à partir de développer une
espèce très intelligente à partir d'un
céphalopode ouais ça implique une
altération drastique du mode de
reproduction justement pour qu'ils
puissent vivre plus longtemps et que du
coup ils puissent profiter de leur
intelligence plus longtemps c'est ça et
que du coup leur intelligence devienne
un gros facteur de sélection naturelle
c'est ça mais là pour le coup on a tous
je les céphalopodes on à l'organe de
préhension ils en ont des dents au
minimum mais voilà ils ont tout ce qu'il
faut ils ont déjà une intimité bras
spécialisés pour ce canton d'ici sont
des bras spécialisée dans la prévention
de voilà donc c
les céphalopodes ce serait une très
bonne chance mais sa demande ce serait
une très bonne chance d'avoir un
scénario alternatif en dehors des
primates et en dehors des vertébrés même
oui mais ça commence à demain changement
ça demande une altération du cycle de
reproduction et altérer les cycles de
reproduction
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué ça sans
même la base de celle là c'est la base
du jeu ma pauvre est la reproduction
c'est toute la base du jeu donc tu
touche pas la reproduction comme ça
c'est pas pour rien que la plupart des
classifications sont basés sur les
organes reproducteurs chez les plantes
c'est le cas les mammifères c'est vous
avez la division de base qui est mono
traîne marsupiaux placentaire elle est
basée sur le système reproducteur my
pourquoi pas ce que tu fais pas le con
avec la reproduction
celanese seles sur la visite de l'espèce
et les grawls la raison pour laquelle on
utilise des organes reproducteurs c'est
parce qu'ils sont remarquablement
stables même à travers des espèces très
différentes
les touts les marsupiaux de la petite de
la petite comme on appelle sa toque
marsupial jusqu'au gigantesque dit proto
dont tous les marsupiaux se reproduise
de la même façon de tout les places
inter se reproduise de la même façon du
de la plus petite des souris jusqu'aux
plus grands des éléphants ou la baleine
bleue alors après on les aime les
baleines vous imaginez ouais là où il
faut imaginer c'est ça même les baleines
les baleines bref pour en revenir à ce
qu'on disait voilà on fait pas le court
avec le système de reproduction et du
coup les poulpes d'aller poulpe ils sont
mal barrés du coup pour être un espèce
intelligente repris il ya moyen
d'altérer la durée
de la reproduction plus qu' étant celle
au zoo se voit pas mal et puis j'aime à
me faire aussi jeter leur typique manche
et d'incubation des oeufs savary ça
varie grandement sur les espèces sur la
taille de l'animal tout simplement bien
chez les mammifères a aussi la durée de
gestation simplement ou quand est-ce
qu'on se reproduit dans l'année car chez
l'homme c'est un petit peu délicat mais
après pour les autres animaux
généralement les cycles donc il ya une
certaine période de l'année à laquelle
on se reproduit ou bien c'est un cycle
comme l'amont et fertile à un certain
moment et puis par un autre et puis
voilà donc ça ça peut être altérée oui
mais du coup il se reproduira super ici
peuvent se reproduire par exemple si
jamais il arrive à bouger la
reproduction
après je pars une dizaine d'années c'est
à dire que tu vis ta vie pendant dix ans
et puis à la fin tu te reproduit
seulement là ce serait mal à sa demande
une ce qu'on appelle une p2 morphose du
coup d'une paix de morphosys
ultraviolente quel train d'y entrer mais
c'est l'arrêt cardiaque et atlas pendant
la moitié de ta vie quoi c'est un peu le
problème aussi pour un céphalopode le
céphalopode après ils sont pas létales
et l'art pendant pendant deux ans
non mais justement vu que la croissance
ralentit il serait à l'état de l'armp en
beaucoup plus longtemps donc vulnérable
extrêmement vulnérables bref pour
conclure ainsi la crise permis à nancy
la crise qu est assez tertiaire n'avait
pas lieu trop haut dans serait-il devenu
intelligent non non non très peu de
chances très peu de chance il ya un
scénario il ya une possibilité
donc il ya un gros cerveau pas forcément
pour qu'ils
je pense qu'elle est à plus d'une main
enfin là quand même faut pas exagérer il
ya un an un peu trop d'hypothèses c'est
pas voilà y'a one shot pour qu'ils
deviennent super pour qui deux pour
qu'il ait un gros cerveau et que par
acidd ans éventuellement ce gros cerveau
lui donne de l'intelligence mais il
accueille wan chai pas gagner c'est
vraiment pas gagné il ya que one shot et
e et 6,6 l'homo sapiens n'était pas l'
espèce intelligente sur terre quelle
espèce pourrait être intelligent ce
genre mais j'avais envie de dire quelles
espèces le remplacerait mais de toute
façon l'intelligence n'étant pas une fin
en soi il n'ya rien qui le remplacerait
il n'y a pas besoin d' espèce
intelligente mais monde n'a pas besoin
d' espèce intelligente on a plus ou
moins construit notre niche écologique
oui bah ouais c'est exactement ça c'est
près de notre intelligence nous a fait
construire notre propre niche écologique
son histoire de survie c'est à dire
qu'on était poussée de l'autre niche
écologique a bien fallu s'adapter
l'adaptation en question et l
intelligence moi c'est tout c'est pas
donc voilà donc à moins qu'une autre
espèce qui a déjà de base un cerveau
comparable à celui d'un primate du
primate qu'on était à l'époque
donc il ya déjà les facultés de base on
va dire que cette espèce rencontre des
circonstances qui ont été similaires aux
nôtres
éventuellement on aurait une autre
espèce intelligente
la grande question c'est éventuellement
ça peut être un éléphant justement un
éléphant qui passe deux herbivores
carnivores il n'est pas équipé pour ça
donc il faut qu'il se fabrique des
petits bouts pointus avec sa petite
trompe ça défend qui commence à
fabriquer des lances avec si vous voyez
un éléphant qui commence à fabriquer une
lance avec une trop avec sa trompe kurek
c'est une nouvelle étape de l'évolution
l'armée courir ça veut dire qu'il a
compris ça veut dire qu'il a tout
compris venir on est foutus
donc voilà éventuellement un éléphant
qui se met à fabriquer une lance
et à bouffer de la viande est bas ce
serait ce serait le meilleur candidat
alors la bouffe et à viande à excédents
je suis pas si oui mais justement nous
on avait des dents pourries pour bouffer
de la viande mais c'est pour ça on a
fait des outils on à me domestique et le
feu entre guillemets comme on dit
domestiques ont dit pas domestiqué
maîtriser maîtriser ouais donc on a
fabriqué des outils on a maîtrisé le feu
c'est aussi pour ça maintenant qu'on a
ici petites bouchées parce qu'on a
appris à dix on a appris après digérer
notre notre nourriture
oui on a fabriqué ce qu'il fallait pour
prédigéré notre nourriture
bonjour la cuisine dans la cuisine ouais
c'est plus joli de dire qu'on a appris à
cuisiner qu'après digérer mais c'est
finalement c'est ça je veux dire ce
qu'on mange c'est des repas prédigéré
après et des animaux qui font ça mais
dans ce cas là il le digère pour leurs
petits oui c'est assez dégoûtant oui
mais voilà c'est ça l'idée c'est que y'a
voilà on n'est pas équipé pour manger ce
qu'on mange mais heureusement on a on a
nos mains qui permettent de prédire et
on a des intestins trop court on a des
vrais matchs et pendant justement on
aurait des intestins trop long pour des
carnivores pour des carnivores street
pour des carnivores strict on aurait des
intestins trop long on n'a pas les dents
qu'il faut mais du coup vu qu'on prédit
gerbe bassoues va bien tout va bien donc
voila merci sophy d'avoir rapporté des
lumières donc voilà on espère que ça
vous aura plu et on vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne ciao ciao